this is a very interesting topic i
found the study that demonstrated
that you could actually reduce your
liver fat by almost 50 in just two
weeks and i'm not kidding this is not a joke this
is a credible study there's a 14-day intervention
study putting people on a carbohydrate restrictive
diet this is called the ketogenic diet where they
consumed less than 30 grams of carbohydrates per
day and this demonstrated decreased liver fat
by 43.8 percent so it's not actually 50
but it's close in subjects with obesity and
what is that non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
now there are several other interesting things
about this number one there wasn't much weight
loss on average there was only like a 1.8 percent
weight loss which is pretty insignificant and
there is no change in waist circumference now
this is very good information to know because
if you started a ketogenic diet and you lost
hardly any weight the first week
and there's no change in your waste
you might just quit and think it's not working
apparently the body gets rid of liver fat
and organ fat as a priority before
it goes after other types of fat
and apparently the loss of liver fat was due to
decreased something called d noble lipogenesis
what is that that means there's a greatly reduced
conversion from carbohydrates to fat there's like
a 79.8 percent decrease so no longer are we
getting this conversion from carbohydrates
to fat and there was also an increase in actual
overall fat burning called fatty acid oxidation
by just under 5x so we had this five times
greater fat oxidation or fat burning effect
in the liver amazing now there's some also very
interesting additional things on this study
first of all the participants did not lower
their calories the average amount of calories
per day was over three thousand so this was not
a globe calorie diet there was also significant
lower markers for liver damage significant lower
fasting insulin levels and lowered homa ir which
means there was less insulin resistance there
was improved insulin sensitivity there was lower
liver inflammation and there was a rapid increase
in folate producing bacteria and folate in their
blood so apparently in the ketogenic diet your
microbes make more folate now what is up with this
folate what does the folate do in relationship
to your liver well it improves liver fat
metabolism and it keeps liver inflammation on
the low side and they found 94 bacterial strains
were altered after going on this low carb
diet with major shifts in microbes occurring
just in one day if you're new to my channel or
you're not new you've been watching my videos and
you haven't started ketogenic diet i think this
right here is a good enough reason to get started
right away so i put a link down below the exact
version of the ketogenic diet you need to start
immediately check it out hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my content
i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below